[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale il est
télévision locale vous présente
le club des territoires
et avec nous pour ce club aujourd'hui
on va parler avec vous de la politique
migratoire des milliers de migrants sont
arrivés sur l'île italienne de Lampedusa
ces derniers jours Marion maréchal et
Marine Le Pen étaient en Italie et
combien chacune imposait ce thème dans
la campagne des européennes alors se
transformera-t-elle en un référendum sur
l'immigration vous nous direz ce que
vous en pensez et puis Alex avec vous on
va parler d'un débat des banques pour
Fabien Roussel et d'orchidée
effectivement Fabien Roussel face à
Édouard Philippe à la Fête de l'Humanité
vous allez voir c'est un débat
intéressants vers ça avec vous dans
quelques instants d'abord on fait le
point comme tous les jours sur la
campagne des sénatoriales
[Musique]
et la campagne des sénatoriales du côté
de l'Oise aujourd'hui où on retrouve
Jean-Marc chevaucher bonjour Jean-Marc
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
Jean-Marc rédacteur en chef adjoint du
Courrier Picard on va parler avec vous
des sénatoriales dans l'Oise dites-nous
tous sénatorial dans loisirs
actuellement trois sénateurs de droite
une sénatrice de gauche est-ce que les
rapports de force sont toujours les
mêmes
vous savez le département de l'Oise est
un département de droite la droite
républicaine il fait toujours
d'excellents scores cette fois-ci elle a
été à égalité avec le RN puisque au
dernier législatives on a désormais
trois députés RN 3 députés LR et un
député macroniste pour ces sénatoriales
vous avez huit listes alors le PS a
réussi enfin comme il le souhaitait
depuis très longtemps dans l'Oise à se
débarrasser de Laurence Rossignol qui va
aller atterrir dans le Val-de-Marne une
sénatrice très connue au Palais du
Luxembourg et désormais vous avez un PS
qui est représenté par un un jeune PS
qui est plutôt inconnu mais à droite il
y a trois sénateurs sortants Olivier
Pacaud sénateur sortant qui s'était
présenté seul la dernière fois édouard
Courtial ancien ministre de Nicolas
Sarkozy et Jérôme Bacher alors tout cela
fait
trois personnalités qui sont apparentées
au groupe LR ou membres du groupe LR au
Sénat et puis ensuite vous avez le
rassemblement national ensuite il y a
aussi une autre macroniste qui est élu
de Senlis et puis il y a aussi un maire
qui a fait une liste qui s'appelle
Stanislas Barthélemy qui a fait une
liste dont il dit qu'elle est de la
majorité présidentielle même si les
macronistes ne le reconnaissent pas et
puis ensuite il y a encore une liste de
l'Union Populaire écologiste et social
qui est menée par une élue de Beauvais
de la France insoumise alors vous voyez
tout cela fait 8 listes voilà les les
sondages les sondages ou le la
connaissance qu'on a du territoire nous
disent que les trois sortants Olivier
Pacaud Édouard courscial Jérôme bachère
même divisé peuvent espérer être
une poussée Jean-Marc un chevauché il y
a une poussée du rassemblement national
vous le disiez lors des dernières
élections est-ce que le rassemblement
national a des chances de faire un siège
non si on vous écoute
vous savez c'est un petit peu toujours
pareil avec le rassemblement national en
ce qui concerne les sénatoriales c'est
vu le mode d'élection voilà c'est c'est
un petit peu compliqué pour eux
d'arriver à faire des voix chez les
grands électeurs parce qu'il faut pour
ça avoir des conseils municipaux alors
si dans les petites communes parfois ils
y arrivent même si il progresse
régulièrement on en est pas encore tout
à fait là alors avoir
un élu RN votre invité précédent vous
direz que c'est sans doute possible dans
l'Oise
ça nous paraît tout de même un petit peu
difficile vu la la réalité des élus vous
savez le lois c'est aussi le département
des rives vertes qui est à Chantilly ça
représente quand même quelques quelques
voies de grands électeurs et puis dans
toute son ancienne circonscription il y
a aussi encore beaucoup de gens qui sont
qui sont attachés à
personnalité donc ça peut faire des voix
sur les sur les listes qui se qui se
réclament du macronisme
sénatorial dans l'Oise avec vous
Courrier Picard dans son édition de loi
ce sont les vendanges vendanges dans un
village de l'Oise c'est à la Une de
votre journal ce matin merci beaucoup
Jean-Marc chevaucher alors l'eau à sa
illustre la division de la droite Alex
un mot peut-être pour expliquer pourquoi
il y a trois listes de droite
effectivement ces divisions de la droite
dans ce scrutin au-delà des différents
politiques et bien elle s'explique par
les règles de l'élection sénatoriale
dans les scrutins proportionnels les
scrutins de liste il faut avoir des
listes paritaires c'est-à-dire et bien
un homme fait une femme ou un versement
un homme une femme un homme une femme et
donc certains sénateurs sortants voulant
être réélu préfère faire des listes
différentes plutôt que ce retrouver
relégué sur une liste commune merci Alex
pour ces explications
l'Oise ça illustre les divisions de la
droite c'est pas le seul département la
droite par jour alors ça existe ils ont
de la droite c'est c'est la droite à
l'intérieur de la droite c'est à dire
que vous avez plusieurs divisions à
droite vous avez la division entre
reconquête le rassemblement national les
républicains on peut considérer qu'une
partie du parti enfin de la majorité
présidentielle représente la droite et
puis vous avez les divisions à
l'intérieur des républicains et vous
souder que la semaine dernière on
parlait des divisions à Paris avec trois
semble-t-il trois listes ben là c'est
pareil si j'écoute notre interlocuteur
et si j'ai bien compris on a la même
chose dans l'Oise et alors il y a le
l'effet Chabada Chabada ça c'est comme
ça qu'on vit pour revenir à Claude
Lelouch mais il y a aussi
cinématographique
il y a aussi des histoires de
sensibilité et surtout des histoires de
susceptibilité c'est plus c'est
davantage non il y a deux marqueurs si
vous voulez moi je connais pas
suffisamment le terrain de l'Oise donc
je vais pas m'aventurer sur un terrain
qui est que je connais pas bien mais ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il y a deux
intérêts à cette élection qui est une
élection importante c'est savoir si le
rassemblement national va pouvoir entrer
ou parler du Luxembourg et puis savoir
si la France insoumise va pouvoir aussi
s'y faire une place parce que c'est deux
parties qui finalement aujourd'hui
structures pas mal et politique
française mais qui sont absents de cette
de cette enceinte c'est vrai que ça rend
un peu nostalgique de la politique à
l'ancienne parce qu'on se rend compte
que le seul PS ou LR en l'occurrence
sont extrêmement fragilisés au niveau
national enchaîne des convenu sur des
convenus mais reste extrêmement puissant
au niveau local et les grands électeurs
qui sont qui votent aussi notorial à ce
sont des représentants des vieux partis
donc ils peuvent encore se permettre de
se diviser tout en étant élu à la fin
malgré tout donc c'est voilà c'est c'est
un peu ça nous rajeunit
elle est arrivée juste avant Ursula
Fender la hyène la présidente de la
commission Marion maréchal a choisi
Lampedusa pour lancer vraiment sa
campagne pour les élections européennes
depuis une semaine en raison notamment
des conditions météorologiques plus de
8500 migrants sont arrivés ici c'est
plus que la population de Lille
l'occasion idéale pour la candidate
reconquête le parti d'Éric Zemmour de
dénoncer ce qu'elle appelle un cas où
migratoires je souhaite être ici pour
appeler un changement de politique au
niveau européen
[Musique]
et d'envoyer des signaux d'ouverture
1700 km plus au nord de l'Italie près de
Bergame sa tante aussi est en campagne
aux côtés elle de Matteo Salvini le
leader de la Ligue un match à l'extrême
droite pour Marine Le Pen la chef de fil
du RN et Marion maréchal sa nièce
soutient d'Éric Zemmour nous
défendre
Marine Le Pen et son allié Matéo Salvini
tente de glaner des voix chez les
eurosceptiques en pointant Bruxelles
comme responsable de cette crise
migratoire Emmanuel Macron de son côté
en a profité pour pointer lui l'échec de
la politique nationaliste de l'Italie
notre devoir à tous européen c'est de ne
pas laisser l'Italie seul mais ceci
montre si je puis me permettre cette
remarque
que les approches strictement
nationalistes on leur limite
l'immigration qui sera au programme des
prochaines réunions des chefs d'État et
de gouvernement devraient aussi occuper
une grande partie de la campagne pour
les européennes et on le voit en
reconquête le rassemblement national
Jean-Baptiste qui tombe d'imposer ce
thème de l'immigration est-ce que ce
week-end aussi bien reconquête que le RN
a lancé sa campagne des européennes
ce qu'on voit sur sur ce thème de
l'immigration c'est que ça leur permet
d'illustrer son heureux les limites de
l'Europe donc c'est quand même
extrêmement favorable pour pour eux de
lancer celle de la campagne là-dessus
après c'est un thème à double tranchant
aussi pour pour le rassemblement
national parce que on a vu défiler ces
derniers jours Marion maréchal et Marine
Le Pen hier en Italie un Italie qui est
quand même pas du tout au même endroit
au même endroit pas au même endroit
exactement alors on pourrait partir dans
comment dire des micro détails sur le
fait que une est plutôt avec Matteo
Salvini et l'autre plutôt à soutenir
dans jamais Meloni exactement la même
extrême droite italienne mais toujours
est-il que l'Italie c'est un pays où
l'extrême droite et au pouvoir c'est un
pays où Georgia Meloni a fait campagne
sur un extrait de manière extrêmement
dur sur une immigration zéro Georgia
Meloni est au pouvoir aujourd'hui on
voit qu'elle est obligée de tendre la
main de composer avec l'Europe donc
quelque part c'est un petit peu
comment dire à double tranchant dans le
sens où ça montre aussi les limites d'un
discours extrêmement dur et nationaliste
vis-à-vis de l'Europe ça montre que
quand après avoir obtenu ce discours
dans une campagne en accède au pouvoir
comme c'est le cas pour Georges Meloni
on n'est pas capable on en a pas les
moyens donc si il peut y avoir un côté
un peu tripal sur l'immigration qui peut
faire un tabac dans dans l'électorat un
peu inquiet au niveau identitaire en
France et quand on réfléchit deux
secondes on voit à quel point le les
solutions sont inaptes donc ça veut dire
que c'est risqué pour Marine Le Pen et
pour reconquête ça peut le revenir en
boomerang ça peut leur revenir au moment
que ça dépend aussi à quel point les
autres parties arriveront à discuter de
fond arriveront à mettre des arguments
et à montrer que il y a quand même un
truc des simpliste si on a quand même un
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin
Québec exactement à gauchiste aussi il
suffisait d'appuyer sur un bouton pour
régler près de l'immigration je pense
qu'il l'aurait trouvé dans quelques
secondes Gérald Darmanin
c'est un atout cette de faire de
l'immigration un thème de campagne pour
le RN et reconquête où est-ce qu'on va
leur renvoyer ben regardez ce que fait
déjà Mélanie ça marche pas
je veux dire c'est un sujet qui est
tellement dramatique c'est terrible de
se dire ça et qui ne fait que qui n'est
pas de faire que de s'amplifier parce
que comme vous voyez la situation
aujourd'hui en Afrique subsaharienne ou
arabe vous voyez que la situation elle
est guère brillante et que toutes les
facteurs sont réunis pour pousser à
l'émigration c'est à dire ce que c'est
c'est ressortissants du Sahel d'Afrique
de l'Ouest ou d'Afrique du Nord et bien
quittent leur pays regardez le drame qui
se joue aujourd'hui en Libye c'est
absolument terrible quoi donc ça c'est
une première chose après vous avez
effectivement les parties de la droite
de la droite qui ont toujours eu ce
discours hostile à l'immigration en
disant il faut fermer les frontières
donc
hostile à l'émigration dit hostiles à
l'Europe
c'est l'Europe qui marche pas c'est
l'Europe qui déraille c'est l'Europe
ce discours bégayait il y a un
bégaiement du discours depuis 40 depuis
30 ans quasiment on retrouve toujours
les mêmes et on a toujours pas trouvé la
solution et personne ne trouve la
solution
honnête
sans faire de promesses inconsidérée
comme le sont souvent justement les
parties d'extrême droite donc le
problème il est là si vous voulez c'est
qu'ils vont prospérer ces parties vont
peut-être prospérer sur ce sujet là mais
je doute qu'il puisse régler quoi que ce
soit on le voit avec Madame mélodie
madame les mélanie a eu un discours très
ferme pour se faire élire et maintenant
elle voit que c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que ça
parce que quand vous tant que vous aurez
pas réglé le problème des pays d'origine
des pays de départ
vous vous retrouverez avec
nécessairement des goulots
d'étranglement et avec Marine Le Pen qui
prend cette distance avec Georgia Meloni
et et qui presque lui reproche dans la
plaie à l'Union européenne oui mais
d'accord mais Madame Le Pen qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire
c'est ça le sujet si vous voulez alors
je veux bien il y a un autre discours
qui consiste à dire on est trop généreux
c'est à dire que là le modèle français
d'accueil est un modèle trop généreux
certes peut-être c'est c'est sans doute
le cas d'ailleurs par rapport à d'autres
pays européens mais vous voyez bien que
l'Allemagne est aussi très
croule sous la demande vous voyez bien
que la Grande-Bretagne qui n'est plus
dans l'Europe et bien elle aussi est
exposée à une très très forte
immigration le problème est compliqué
beaucoup plus compliqué que ce que veut
bien dire monsieur Zemmour et Marine Le
Pen qui s'était un peu détachée de ce
thème de l'immigration ces derniers mois
ces dernières années pour faire des
discours plus sociaux on l'a vu
notamment dans son discours de rentrée
est-ce que là du coup elle revient
peut-être malgré elle malgré la centaine
d'origine alors elle y revient mais ce
que quand vous parlez de discours plus
sociaux en fait elle a une sorte de
double enjeu pour Marine Le Pen il y a
un enjeu quand même de crédibilité
d'institutionnalisation de son parti en
général d'où sa déclaration des droits
des peuples et des états quels qu'elle a
voulu présenter sous Ken sur quand même
l'idée que elle fait un peu plus du haut
de gamme qu'auparavant c'est à dire que
c'est pu c'est plus de l'extrême droite
qui tâche on comment dire on réfléchit
on essaye de trouver des ponts avec des
alliés européens en théorise un peu plus
un peu plus tout ça et par ailleurs elle
a au niveau national son discours
économique qui est pas clair du tout qui
est toujours dans une forme de démagogie
de de promesses un peu un peu intenable
et c'est là qu'il y a une compétition
intéressante avec avec reconquête qui
joue davantage l'Union des droites avec
un discours économique beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus libérale à l'ancienne
qu'on pourrait rapprocher du rassemble
une fin du Front national de Jean-Marie
Le Pen dans les années 80-90 qui était
beaucoup plus regagnant beaucoup plus
dans une forme de de de dérégulation et
donc voilà il y a un enjeu de cohérence
pour me permettre pour Marine Le Pen à
ce niveau là
elle essaie de faire les deux elle a
compris qu'il fallait qu'elle est un
discours
social puisque ça lui a réussi d'une
certaine façon même si elle n'a pas été
élu président de la République c'est
quand même un discours qui l'a porté et
c'est distingué justement de l'examen de
ce point de vue et j'ai beaucoup un
discours beaucoup plus libéral et le
libéralisme en France c'est compliqué à
faire comprendre et puis à côté elle a
jamais perdu ses discours c'est parce
que elle a fait dominer son aspect
social mais elle a jamais abandonné ces
thèmes qui sont les thèmes sur la
sécurité sur les migrations dès qu'il
faut les ressortir je dirais que le kit
de l'orgas est prêt et puis Marine Le
Pen a aussi une échéance sur le plan
national qui concerne l'immigration
c'est le projet de loi immigration du
gouvernement tous les partis voilà et
avec un projet de loi avec deux jambes
une jambe de droite un volet répressif
sur l'immigration régulière et puis une
jambe de plutôt social avec des mesures
de régularisation des travailleurs sans
papiers et le rassemblement national est
bien il discute avec Emmanuel Macron il
demande un référendum sur les migration
et des mesures fortes on verra si Marine
Le Pen va vraiment être constructive
avec le président pour trouver un accord
sur ce texte
une forme de répartition des tâches au
sein du rassemblement national avec
peut-être un jardin Bardella qui
s'adresse plus à la droite et Marine Le
Pen qui essaye plus de rassembler le
sang devant le centre gauche ce qu'il y
a effectivement ce discours social dont
on parlait que davantage incarné Marine
Le Pen et on a vu qu'il y a eu des
prises de position un peu plus
pro-entreprises pro business de Jordan
bardah de Jordan Bardella ces derniers
temps ce qui selon moi est plutôt une
façon de répondre à la montée en
puissance en tout cas à la menace de
reconquête qui qui a un discours
davantage libéral qui joue davantage
celui de l'Union des droites si vous
prenez l'électorat de LR que se dispute
encore en espérant le dépecer le
rassemblement national le rassemblement
national et reconquête c'est pas un
électorat qui va être sensible aux
grandes envolées sociales
un peu irréaliste économiquement que
peut avoir Marine Le Pen donc il y a il
y a cet enjeu à essayer de jouer un peu
sur les deux tableaux comme on parlait
aussi d'un rassemblement national du
Nord et à rassemblement rassemblement
national du Sud plus plus droitier entre
guillemets sur les questions y compris y
compris économiques voilà il y a cette
répartition des rôles entre les deux et
la majorité l'exécutif ne se prive pas
d'attaquer Marine Le Pen sur ce sujet de
l'immigration on va écouter le ministre
de l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin était
invité ce matin de la matinale de cnews
et d'Europe
situation politique un peu étonnante ou
la France trouve une solution la demande
d'asile aux frontières beaucoup plus
efficace le gouvernement de Madame
Meloni dans quel parti peut se Salvini
est d'accord avec cette proposition
simplement ceux qui bloque ça au
Parlement européen c'est rassemblement
national qui après vent en Italie pour
dire que ne fait rien sauf que du
tourisme électoral de la part de Madame
Le Pen il faut désormais être ferme
tourisme électoral il y a un double jeu
du rassemblement national entre ce qu'il
faut au Parlement européen et ce qu'il
fait sur certains
spectateurs sont peut-être pas très au
courant qu'il y a un éclatement de la de
l'extrême droite au Parlement européen
ils sont pas tous ensemble il y a des
sensibilités et c'est vrai que très
souvent c'est la politique de la chaise
vide alors que il y a des sujets
importants qui sont en discussion et ils
ne mettent pas les en accord leur leurs
actes avec leurs paroles
va appuyer là dessus durant cette
campagne des européennes
on voyait la réponse d'Emmanuel Macron
on voit bien qu'il va aller pointer les
les incohérences des réponses uniquement
nationalistes populistes parce que comme
on l'a dit tout à l'heure dès que les
populistes les nationalistes sont au
pouvoir qu'est-ce qu'ils font de la main
à l'Europe malgré tout donc
effectivement ça montre aussi le côté
inapte de leur de leur démonstration sur
l'Europe
de ce club on va parler d'un débat Alex
c'est un débat qui avait lieu hier entre
Fabien Roussel et Édouard Philippe à la
fête de l'humain et oui alors au début
de ce débat l'accueil a été un peu
mouvementée pour Edouard Philippe
l'ancien Premier ministre qui n'était
pas en terrain conquis et d'ailleurs au
début de ce débat et bien un militant
qui se présente se prétendait gilet
jaune a fait éruption sur la scène
regardez
il n'y a rien à faire
[Applaudissements]
voilà alors passer ce coup d'éclat et
bien le débat a pu avoir lieu entre le
patron du Parti communiste et celui du
parti horizon alors forcément il n'avait
pas la même vision de la politique
amener pour le pays mais Édouard
Philippe a trouvé des convergences avec
Fabien Roussel notamment sur la question
du nucléaire ce sont deux pronucléaires
et dans ce débat et bien Fabien Roussel
a dénoncé je cite à la bêtise des
parties de gauche qui sont opposées au
nucléaire donc les écologistes
apprécieront et puis Édouard Philippe
lui a expliqué qu'il travaillait au
quotidien avec les élus communistes dans
sa ville du Havre et que dans une
élection et bien quand il y avait un
face à face entre un candidat communiste
et un candidat du Front National et bien
il ne les avait jamais mis sur le même
plan écoutez
alors de son côté Fabien Roussel a aussi
trouvé une convergence avec son rivale
de droite l'importance de diminuer la
dette du pays mais pour y arriver et
bien il n'a pas les mêmes méthodes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à vous de payer un peu continuer
participer et puis Fabien Roussel est
revenu sur sa sortie polémique il y a
quelques jours ce qu'on appelle envahir
les préfectures pour protester contre
l'inflation et il a essayé de préciser
les choses
[Applaudissements]
il ne s'agit pas pour nous de venir
défoncer les grilles des préfectures de
les envoyer avec des fourches avec des
faux-cils et des marteaux avec des
prisons avec des ouvriers
[Applaudissements]
voilà alors à travers ce débat avec
Édouard Philippe et bien le but de
Fabien Roussel c'était d'opposé un
projet de droite libéral et son projet
de gauche mais on peut dire aussi que
son intention c'était de faire un débat
entre deux hommes qui préparent
activement la présidentielle 2027
c'était surprenant ce choix de débat
entre Fabien Rousselin
Roussel on connaît il est plutôt
disruptif c'est un mot à la mode dans la
gauche il veut s'affirmer comme étant
une gauche de bon sens il veut
s'affirmer comme une grosse de travail
il veut s'affirmer comme étant une
gauche de dialogue le contraire en fait
de ce que fait
Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais est-ce que ces
couronnées de succès j'ai envie de dire
pour nos bandes non c'est pas Corona de
succès cette gauche là de cette gauche
et là encore un électorat c'est la
grosse question c'est une question que
d'ailleurs l'élection sénatoriale à
laquelle l'élection sénatoriale ne va
pas répondre parce que c'est une
élection très particulière mais je suis
curieux de voir si aux européennes par
exemple c'est une élection où il y a
énormément d'abstention et bien ça peut
avoir quelques succès on verra le fait
il y a 5 ans pour l'école bien sûr et je
pense que les prochaines seront encore
difficiles donc
c'est ça qui va être intéressant comme
les parties de gauche vont partir
séparées divisé l'élection européenne on
va pouvoir et bien estimer leur force de
frappe l'intérêt pour pour Édouard
Philippe c'est quoi Jean-Baptiste c'est
de montrer qu'il y a une gauche avec
laquelle il peut discuter
le débat entre le mec de gauche préféré
de la droite et le mec de droite
préférée de la gauche ce qui non mais ce
qui leur va bien il y a clairement un
intérêt commun Édouard Philippe il a une
façon de se positionner qui est assez à
la fois paradox paradoxal et
intéressantes qui est de se construire
une après avoir servi Emmanuel Macron
pendant trois ans une stature assez
qualifier de droite un peu à l'ancienne
finalement sur sur l'immigration sur
l'économie quand il parle de retrait
jusqu'à 65 65 66 67 ans et en même temps
de manière assez paradoxale quand on
regarde des études d'opinion on voit que
il y a environ un quart des électeurs
qui se définissent comme de gauche qui
disent je pourrais voter pour lui donc
si votre pour lui c'est pas parce qu'il
propose des retraites pourquoi pas
jusqu'à 67 ans c'est aussi pour une
question d'attitude c'est aussi pour une
question de statut finalement c'est
l'argument de se dire que s'il arrivait
au pouvoir bah ce serait pas si
catastrophique que ça parce qu'il y
aurait malgré tout une sorte de socle de
de valeur commune qui serait qui serait
respectée une forme de tolérance aussi
des des comment dire des des points
communs sur les valeurs républicaines
avec des gens comme de l'autre côté
comme Bernard Cazeneuve par exemple
voilà ce côté un peu des hommes d'État
un peu à l'ancienne qui finalement par
les temps qui courent qui sont assez
hystériques sont sont
[Musique]
dans le discours de rentrée d'Édouard
Philippe à Angers vendredi dernier il y
a eu cette question du pouvoir d'achat
où il a dit qu'il donnait le point entre
guillemets à Gérald Darmanin d'avoir
alerté à ce sujet là de dire qu'il y
avait des carences dans le bilan de
d'Emmanuel Macron sur sur cette question
du peu du pouvoir d'achat des classes
populaires et c'était quelque chose qui
était un petit peu absent dans dans son
discours parfois Édouard Philippe il
peut avoir un côté un peu
stratosphérique à parler de la France à
10 15 20 ans à parler de nucléaire a
parlé de convention franco-algérienne
sur l'immigration c'est pas forcément
des thèmes hyper quotidien pour les
Français le pouvoir d'achat c'était une
critique qui lui était faite de pas en
parler suffisamment et là effectivement
il vient après par rapport à ce que vous
disiez précédemment aussi pour Édouard
Philippe qui a une question de
effectivement de la droite de de comment
on gagne en 2027 ça peut pas être ça
peut plus être exactement avec le même
bloc central quand on en parle avec des
projets dedouard Philippe on voit qu'ils
ont ils sont déjà dans une logique de
coalition c'est à dire on gagnera pas
tout seul il faut aussi avoir avoir des
pompes de manière extrêmement négociée
pourquoi pas aussi avec avec un centre
gauche donc c'est aussi tout ça qui se
prépare une une sorte de d'ouverture sur
les sujets sur les réseaux sur les
sujets sociaux mais aussi de capacité à
dialoguer négocier pourquoi pas bâtir un
accord de gouvernement avec un centre
gauche il peut la rassembler cette
gauche là Édouard Philippe est-ce qu'il
peut ramener à lui des électeurs qui
votent aujourd'hui Fabien Roussel
en marge marginalement marginalement je
pense qu'il va y avoir
un encombrement au centre au centre du
dispositif du paysage politique français
Édouard Philippe et le favori pour le
moment est-ce que ça va durer mon avis
il va y avoir 5 6 7 8 9 peut-être
candidats et c'est tout le risque
d'ailleurs c'est que il n'arrive pas à
au bout du bout à s'entendre et que cet
embouteillage
conduise à une opposition qui renforce
et l'extrême droite et l'extrême gauche
et ça c'est le risque majeur qui puisse
exister d'après moi
et qui leur répondaient si et bien il y
a une une rivalité très vive qui se joue
au centre
ce que Jean-Luc Mélenchon était invité
hier soir BFM et il a eu cette phrase je
ne fais pas la nuque parce que j'aime
les autres je ne les aime pas
il a jamais été sans jamais été un grand
philanthrope
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est plutôt le
contraire c'est ce côté tout à fait
étonnant qui qu'il existe qui existe
chez lui
une revanche à prendre sur beaucoup de
choses en fait c'est un homme qui a
souffert on sent qu'il a souffert
psychologiquement souffert socialement
qui a ouvert politiquement il estime
qu'il a jamais été reconnu à sa juste
valeur
au début en tous les cas de ces années
en politique et là il est en train de
prendre sa revanche le problème c'est
que enfin c'est pas un problème
d'ailleurs pour lui c'est qu'à chaque
fois qu'il a eu des propos extrêmement
rudes transgressif violent là ça ne lui
a jamais
[Musique]
ça lui a jamais porté tort finalement et
bah il continue sa route et qui pousse
lui-même à l'éclatement de la nuque où
est-ce qu'il est bien aidé
il a peut-être intérêt à passer avec un
plan de la jupe et c'est ce qui
peut-être fait de temps en temps
où il y a cette dynamique commune qui
qui se crée qui se renforce la question
se pose aussi de qui va qui va la
diriger qui va la représenter à la fin
parce qu'après on disait tout à l'heure
qu'il peut y avoir 5 6 7 candidats pour
ce qui reste de la macronie aujourd'hui
la nuque ça peut être 4 candidats
également donc
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il veut bien mignon
derrière lui il a pas forcément envie
qu'il est quelqu'un d'autre qui vienne
lui piquer le flambeau à la fin donc
doudou la tentation de de dynamiter tout
ça avec ce genre de propos bon c'est du
Jean-Luc Mélenchon oui mais après pour
des raisons de fond encore une fois il a
il a pas forcément intérêt ce que la
nuit prospère trop longtemps donc on en
parlera évidemment merci et merci
Jean-Baptiste vous restez avec nous on
regarde ce qu'elle a une quotidien
[Musique]
et Alex on commence avec la Une de
Sud-Ouest la hausse des prix du
carburant et le gouvernement qui
autorise la vente à perte ce week-end
par Elisabeth borne la première ministre
fini le quoi qu'il en coûte finit les
ristourne de l'État sur le prix à la
pompe le gouvernement se tourne
désormais vers les distributeurs pour
leur permettre de vendre leur carburant
à perte pour baisser davantage les prix
une autorisation de quelques mois et un
projet de loi qui devrait arriver très
vite au Parlement pour concrétiser cette
mesure une annonce qui met en colère en
tout cas les pompistes car ils estiment
qu'ils n'ont actuellement pas les marges
financières pour vendre à perte et puis
cette mesure reste quand même
impuissante contre la hausse du prix du
pétrole au niveau mondial qui continue
en tout cas certains Français n'hésitent
pas à franchir à la frontière pour faire
le plein d'essence c'est le cas en
Moselle ou de plus en plus
d'automobilistes vont au Luxembourg pour
se servir en carburant c'est à la une du
Républicain Lorrain dans le Grand-Duché
le prix du litre de super 95 et par
exemple 30 centimes moins cher on le
précise au Luxembourg c'est l'État qui
fixe un prix plafond pour le litre de
carburant et les stations services sont
alors libres de baisser leurs prix de
quelques centimes pour attirer les
clients notamment français le
gouvernement annonce aujourd'hui un
nouveau plan loup et oui le loup est à
la Une de plusieurs quotidiens régionaux
aujourd'hui Var-Matin le loup se
casse-tête que faire du loup se demande
le populaire du centre les taux se
resserre autour du loup à titre le
journal Le Télégramme alors concrètement
avec ce nouveau plan loup du
gouvernement et bien les protocoles de
tir vont être simplifiés mais le quota
de loup a tué ne devrait pas augmenter à
savoir 19% de la population de cette
espèce à la fin de l'hiver 2023 plus de
1100 loups avaient été recensés en
France soit le double par rapport à il y
a 5 ans et aujourd'hui les loups sont
présents dans 55 départements français
et puis il n'y a pas que les loups qui
posent des problèmes aux éleveurs il y a
aussi les vautours précisément dans le
pays de l'Aubrac c'est à la Une de
Centre Presse Aveyron plusieurs
troupeaux de bovins ont subi des
attaques de vautours cet été et des
éleveurs ont perdu des bêtes des
vautours qui s'en prennent notamment au
veau ce qui fait paniquer les troupeaux
la ligue de protection des oiseaux qui
est plutôt favorable à un développement
de l'espèce des vautours s'oppose à des
tirs des farouchements des oiseaux et
cela crée des tensions avec les éleveurs
et avec les élus on finit par du foot
résultat sont pas bons pour les deux
olympiques inquiétant titre La Provence
après le match nul de l'Olympique de
Marseille au Vélodrome contre Toulouse
les joueurs marseillais qui ont même été
conspués par les supporters et puis ça
va encore moins bien du côté de
l'Olympique Lyonnais qui reste 16e de
Ligue 1 après un 00 contre Le Havre
c'était la une du Progrès de Lyon le
nouvel entraîneur italien Fabio Grosso
est présenté aujourd'hui à la presse
merci Alex pour cette revue de presse on
regarde brune du Figaro on en a parlé
l'Europe impuissante face à la flûte
migrants nous
occuper pendant de longues années y
compris après les élections européennes
et elle est
en très bon la ligne de Libé inflation
ça a l'air budget pris au piège
manoeuvre budgétaire quel gouvernement
alors que voilà les revendications
sociales autour de la hausse des prix
sont toujours pas éteintes évidemment
merci Jean-Baptiste Daoulas merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous merci ils
vont merci beaucoup la semaine prochaine
merci Alex
[Musique]